سدوله روسيه بين محافظتين منوبه و باجا
شمال غرب تونس واحد من السدود 37 التي
تراجع منسوب تخزينها للمياه بشكل كبير
يعمل فريق من وزاره الفلاحه التونسيه على
اعاده تاهيل بعد ست سنوات من الجفاف حتى
ان خريف هذه السنه لم يكن سخيا سدود تونس
لا تحتوي الا على ربع طاقتها التخزينيه
تقريبا
لم تتجاوز 40% سنويا اليوم احنا همم 37
سنه 29%
وادي مجرد اكبر انهار تونس وشريان مياهنا
نابع من مرتفعات سوق اهراس بالجزائر هكذا
صار منصوب المياه فيها وهكذا صارت وضعيه
الحقول والزراعات المحيطه به
تبقى قنوات نقل المياه من محافظه يا زغوان
وصلت تونس الى العاصمه منذ العهد
الرومانيه وفي وسطيات والاغاربه في العهد
الاسلامي اكبر شاهد على تعاطي سكان تونس
مع ازمه شح المياه عبر التاريخ لكن الازمه
الحاليه خطيره جدا وغير مسبوقه وفقا
المسؤولين وتتطلب حلولا عاجله
[موسيقى]
المهندسين بتونس العاصمه اجتمع مهندسون
وخبراء في الموارد المائيه ووزراء سابقون
لبحث ازمه المياه بعد ست سنوات الاعجاب
صار فيها نصيب المواطن 400 متر مكعب من
المياه في السنه اي تحت خط الفقر المائيه
بينما كان الفا في السنه في الستينات
القرن الماضي الوضعيه خطيره والحلول
العاجله صارت اكثر من اكيده
سبع سنوات
ست سنوات
هام شاف وحده وما يقلقش اما اكيد تبدا
عوام جافه متتاليه هذا هو تم الاشكال
وهذاك اللي حثنا احنا كوزاره نحاولوا مش
نخططوا وباش نقسمه الماء وباش نعت له بين
مياه الشرب ومياه الرجل
ان تونس ان لم تتمكن من حل مشكلات مياه
الري مع بدايه السنه القادمه فستكون دون
مياه شرب الصيف المقبل وليد عبد الله
العربي تونس